called these early stages of one of
these incidents to actually identify and
specify what's exactly happening but it
certainly looks like another one of
these multiple coordinated terrorist
attacks committed in a shot in and to
which of course is a pretty standard and
easy target for anyone that wants to
kill and maim people so really
unfortunate but it seems to be almost a
daily offender a daily activity now
somewhere in the West you say that
security that shopping centers are often
targeted and why are they seen as a soft
target for terrorists or people who want
to go and murder well of course is
there's vital differences between things
like stadiums which are only open for a
certain number of days of the year and a
shopping center which is pretty much
always open seven days a week and fairly
easy and open access to get into so
shopping centers shop in high street and
the light will always be the easiest
target but of course that doesn't help
these poor people have to use it and
we've seen attacks across the world in
locations yet such as this and
unfortunately I think the way the way
the ISIS threat is going I think we're
going to see quite a lot more in the in
the coming months ahead we've seen
images coming out of Munich showing
multiple police vehicles roads being
cleared what do you make of the police
response so far to this incident well
the very first thing you need to do is
to identify and time contain the people
that are that are carrying out these
offenses so the first place response is
actually to to try and locate the person
and then contain them and these days
unfortunate because of the way the
thread has changed whereas in the past
we were trying to contain them and then
talk them out these days unfortunately
we have to or police officers have to go
in and chase down the suspects but it's
very important as well that when the
police officers are doing that that
they're they're not being confronted by
colleagues coming from the other
direction so identification and location
of the suspects is the most important
thing tracking them down and then
unfortunately neutralizing them but
that's the way of the world these days
in front